tiene como es este domingo escribir un
nuevo capítulo de su historia y por las
señales que se dieron en la inauguración
de la convención constitucional será la
historia de un país diferente al que
conocemos hasta ahora la elección de
elisa loncón una mujer mapuche defensora
de las lenguas indígenas académica y de
regiones marca el paradigma de lo que
podría ser un nuevo chile en su discurso
al asumir el cargo un discurso muy
emotivo
loncón mencionó el hecho de que se
trabajará para construir un chile
plurinacional multicultural con enfoque
la igualdad de género que incluye la
diversidad sexual en el que también hay
importancia de los niños y de la
protección del medio ambiente su
discurso fue muy alabado por todo casi
la mayor parte del arco político chileno
y también celebrado por figuras como evo
morales a partir de ahora la convención
constitucional tiene nueve meses
prorrogables durante tres meses más en
total un año para escribir un nuevo
texto destinado a reemplazar a la
constitución de 1980 heredada de augusto
pinochet la convención los 155
componentes 78 hombres 77 mujeres la
primera convención paritaria
se pondrá a trabajar este lunes mismo